while the long-awaited opening of The
Hunt Ridge Theater still ways away but
progress has been made and a relighting
ceremony will take place this Friday
Madison Kimbrough taking us inside as
she joins us live near Charleston in
Maryland with the details hi Madison
we are giving you a behind the scenes
look at what the theater looks like
inside now as we spoke to some key
players who had a hand in making it a
success again take a look
you're going to have a much more
intimate experience be very close to
artists and see new emerging art it's
time to go back to the theater as one of
the most historic venues in town is on
its way to making its debut once again
relighting ceremony will take place this
Friday where the signage and Marquee you
see here will be lit up for the first
time in 20 years
Darren Lee Cole's company Soho Playhouse
will be the operator of the hunt Ridge
bringing Off-Broadway style theater to
The Venue we're building this to be
staffed by local people from Las Vegas
and nevadans and we're to give local
artists an opportunity and a place where
they can apply their trade an architect
Brett robillard telling us that his goal
is to preserve the hunt Bridges
authenticity and history while adding
more amenities for entertainment the
building has great bones there's a lot
of respect that goes into something like
this and we're not we don't want to come
in and just you know do something that's
so grandiose or so
so much of a spectacle into itself that
it takes away from the original theater
and as for Friday hunt Ridge Theater
owner Jay Dapper says he's Beyond
thrilled to finally show the community
their progress as he agrees the wait has
been too long there's been a lot of
people that have worked on trying to
save the building and kind of Bring It
Back to Life I'm hoping that in another
12 months from now we invite you back
and you know we're starting construction
Friday night's event starts at 5 30 here
at Hunt Ridge theater with the
re-lighting ceremony set for 7 15 and
it's open to the public reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now